foreign
joins us in Tupelo Mississippi Jalen
welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing today doing good
how are you Jalen I'm doing good how can
we help
uh yeah so just a quick rundown
um I'm 23 years old I make about 50 000
a year and uh I'm trying to clean up a
big car mistake okay
um how big
uh thirty five thousand dollars worth
that's alone
yes okay
and what's the car worth
so the car is worth uh by Kelly Blue
Book is about 27.5 okay
you got any money in the bank
um not much very little
is that Frozen
uh three three thousand okay uh is that
your only debt
uh no I have about 4 000 in credit cards
we gotta get out of this alone
if I'm you I'm definitely going to get
out of that loan uh it's too much of
your
income you know and if I'm you in this
case it's worth you've got 8K in the
bank no no you've got 3K in the bank
so in this case I would honestly I would
sell it and I would take out a small
little you know go to a credit union and
take a small loan out for that 5K that
you're upside down and you know at that
point
it's worth it for you to get out of
thirty five thousand dollars of debt and
then you can take the money
you know from there we're going to try
to get a cash car after that
how does that sound to you that'll be my
next question I've already um looked at
uh the possibility of getting a loan and
I actually already have a loan I'm just
yet to sign the papers what do you mean
you have alone what kind of loan is this
it's a consolidation loan no no no you
don't want that what are you trying to
consolidate you don't yeah what you only
have two two deals here
well the the cars I'm not going to get
27.5 for the car I've looked around at
the offers and I've been offered uh 25
26. from where I was still uh places
like uh just local dealer dealerships
well yeah you don't want you don't want
to go there I mean you need to do some
homework and Shop everywhere go private
party Craigslist AutoTrader Facebook
Marketplace hey don't don't give out
consolidation don't sign that
don't do that okay it's not helping you
all it is is moving around the debt with
crappier terms and it's not going to get
you out of debt any faster
it'll just make you feel like you did
something yeah how many hours of work
are you working
um it varies I'm on salary so I just I
just work like five six days a week
okay I want you to work more because
what I want to do I want to get you out
of this debt and like I said for me it's
worth getting out of this out of this
car loan but you're going to need to
save up a little bit of money before you
can do that so I want you working so
hard bringing in as much cash as you can
because I want you keeping the 1K as
your starter emergency fund so that
gives you 2K that you may be able to put
towards your next car and I want you to
save up a little bit more money so that
you can get out of this 35k loan and
also be on your way to paying off that
other 4K that you have in debt
all right okay I understand yeah I think
you know it's overwhelming because
you're looking at this and it's like oh
my gosh I just made this huge mistake
and it's really easy to just like try to
jump into a solution that feels like
it's going to solve everything for you
instantly but let me tell you
consolidation that's it's really not the
way a lot of times you end up getting a
bigger interest rate on the on whatever
the consolidation is because it's based
on your credit score they're paying you
money you're paying them money to do
something that you can do yourself
they're not going to pay off the debt
for you you still got to pay the debt
off so what's what you know in this case
it's just not worth it for you at all
like I said
um if you if it takes for you to get a
small loan from a credit union just to
to bridge that gap between the 35k and
you know whatever you're able to sell it
for 25 you know 27 and a half it looks
like it's worth it to do that to get out
of it but I also want you to be able to
get into a cash car so let's work like
crazy man let's get another two three
four K saved up and let's get out of
this thing and let's get a cash card it
doesn't have to be great get yourself a
beater that gets you from point A to
point B do you have a long commute
uh actually I have a work uh vehicle
whoa look dude you're holding out on us
bro can you use that for a while
not the job no okay
so what what do you use the work vehicle
for
uh just work
but do you use it to get to it but you
can't get to work in it yeah I do okay
so when do you use the personal car just
on the weekends
honestly I hate to say it but never
Jayla Jalen Jalen Jalen you are getting
rid of this car today because at this
point bro you just need a beater just
something to get you from a player I use
the Tupelo zip code I sorted low to high
yeah there's some great cars for four
five grand yes and so I'm taking the
person alone getting out of this thing
yes and using that money towards a used
car that you're never even gonna use so
there you go thanks for the college